the American people have no desire to go
to war with Iran at all American people
don't have an appetite for war right now
right now American people don't want to
go to war with for anything no we just
want to fune for another can you imagine
they send our people to fight in Ukraine
our soldiers to fight a war in Ukraine
well they've already deployed thousands
to Europe for the war in Ukraine
disgusting and we have special forces
there these are lives of people they
don't understand that part now I guess
uh Ukraine's kind of falling the back
burner zinski is the you know yeah he's
yesterday's news back on seeking
Arrangement looking for a new sugar
daddy that's right that's right I think
that the the the war in Ukraine is is
been basically decided you okay down
there oh this is so funny it's true I I
mean I don't think that anyone that
serious believes that Russia is going to
give up any of the territory that
they've taken no and I don't see any
reason why the US should keep giving
money to Ukraine